got really difficult when I went to
boarding school and it was all girls and
we had to do like our homework in the
dorms and that's when I struggled I
don't everyone always just remember
school is is really happy time and I
just don't especially kind of erase it
from my memory I still haven't told my
dad I don't know when I will I remember
telling my sister and I was just looking
at her and she didn't actually say
anything
I think she just gave me this really
awful stare and turned around and walked
away but my dad was amazing like he was
like weirdly he was my rock like I think
he got it I think I've really got it I
thinking you I actually Matt he he might
like be the same as me
you know it's like it was when I was
really small actually and my mom's book
club was gathering and I was like
walking to the kitchen I must feel about
like 8:00 and they were talking about
gender construct and Jane Eyre and just
something to code me and then from that
it sort of continued to developed
particularly any ism structuralism
post-structuralism dadaism feminism
Marxism most of them obviously bar
things like fascism that's kind of
separate saying telling somebody on a
first date is a real hurdle I mean be
honest I'm coming out every day and it
takes a lot to prepare yourself to tell
someone this is what my sexual interests
are and this is what I masturbate to and
what I what I think about and what makes
me happy
instead of going out and meet people and
doing normal things all you want to do
is sit in your room and watch a TED talk
and you know masturbate while watching
it sorry there's not an app for it you
know you can't like swipe right and be
like whoohoo someone else is going to
feel the Ginga probe out four of us out
there all I really want is just to meet
somebody like me you know what I'm a
sapiosexual I am a sapiosexual I am a
sapiosexual I am a CPA sexual and I'm
proud and I refuse to apologize anymore
you
you